this is a strange weird bizarre day for
different reasons because it's cba day
you know usually we run the other way
when there's an occasion to talk about
labor discussions but we got no choice
they're forcing us today big cat because
the nfl has put the ball on the t and
has said to the players association it's
time for you to kick it and the
statement that the nfl issued yesterday
was beautiful pr masterpiece because if
a deal doesn't get done it's not the
nfl's fault it's the player's fault okay
hold on wait wait back up back up back
up you saying you run away from cba talk
uh i'll quote uh the the the all-time
coach mike ditka when i say who you
crapping okay that's crazy you love to
talk about this evening yeah
let me be more specific i am forced by
coordinating producer matt casey to run
away from cpa i will suggest for
inclusion into the outline and he will
respond uh either with an emoji of a
middle finger
or something else telling me that no
we're not gonna jam that into the show
but today it's front and center because
we're on the cusp or not of a new cba
and uh look what the nfl did yesterday
was a boss move they convened all the
owners and they officially ratified the
proposal that has been
generated by months of negotiation
that's the one important point that
people need to realize as we go through
the course of friday and wait for the
nflpa to say something in response to
the nfl's current proposal this is not
the first offer this is the product of
nearly a year of negotiation and the
negotiating teams for both the league in
the union decided this is good enough to
take back to our clients well the nfl
clients have said we'll take it now the
question is will the nflpa clients take
it and let's go over some of the big
terms here
assuming that the nflpa ultimately
before march 18 when the new league year
begins we'll accept this deal one key
point we didn't mention last hour most
player discipline will now be handled by
a neutral party that is a key concession
now we don't have the details yet big
cat but that could mean personal conduct
policy no longer will the commissioner
be judge jury and executioner that is a
power that he had been clinging to
for years that is a huge huge win for
the players doesn't cost the owners any
money but it's a huge win for the
players if they can finally get that
power away from the commissioner
okay so i i see all this stuff i
understand it after the first hour we'll
recap real quick so as far as i
understand the cba the nfl has put this
out there for the players to basically
get this signed before march 18th if it
doesn't happen we're going to do this
song and dance next year but
from everything you've read and
everything you've seen and you are a
lawyer
uh you think that this will more likely
than not be signed before march 18th and
we won't even have to sniff an idea of a
work stoppage come a year and a half
from now which is great for all football
fans so
i i threw this at you like what is the
what what is the major hiccup here what
is the spot that you're gonna look at
and you're gonna say this might be where
we we falter this might be where the
players say absolutely not we're not
doing this
like rip it up we'll try again next year
where is that so people can know
well and and let me just back up a step
and and address your point on whether or
not i think this is going to get done
over the weekend i had multiple phone
conversations that led me to believe
this is moving toward getting done and
everything that's happened this week has
continued to push toward this sense that
it's going to get done and what the nfl
did yesterday created an overwhelming
notion that that this is moving toward
its final phases
and i was stunned last night to see jj
watt take to twitter and say hard no on
the cba proposal richard sherman who is
a member of the executive committee
coming out against it i don't know
what's going to happen today and my
impression had been the executive
committee is fine with it if it would
ever get to a vote for the full rank and
file 50 of 1900 dues paying members plus
one
that would get through it's the board of
player representatives and they're
required to endorse it by two-thirds 22
of 32 have to say yes before it even
goes to a vote of all players that's
where i feel like the biggest resistance
is and 17 games big cat continues to be
a sticking point even though
it's inevitable that the owners are
going to get their 17 games and in time
probably 18 games that's where a lot of
the pushback is coming from the players
don't want 17 games and i think maybe as
they get farther away from the end of
the season where they feel like their
bodies have been beaten to a pulp and
they recover maybe they're less inclined
to say hell no to 17 games but i still
feel like that's the core of the concern
there are players who want nothing to do
with 17 games even though i feel like
it's inevitable we're gonna have 17. now
is this the time that you want me to
unveil my perfect nfl schedule that i
have been you know parading around the
country now like a politician do you
want me to do it now or we're gonna do
it later
uh sure go ahead all right i'll give you
my perfect nfl schedule because like you
said 17 games is an is inevitable
two bye weeks i think can be done and
here's how it can be done stop shaking
your head mike florio i'm going to take
you this you do that to me all the time
i'm going to take you to school listen
here's what here's how my schedule works
listen once again one thing i learned
watching watching the debate the other
night you're always on camera when
someone else is ripping you and it is
better to shake your head than to look
like a deer in the headlights either the
other night fair all right 17 games 19
weeks two buys this is easy mike you
have the regular buy that rotates that
everyone knows about so you have two to
four teams taking a bye during the
season that's fine because your main
criticism is that with two buys you will
have too many weeks where there's bad
teams playing not enough you know
marquee match-ups now here's where the
second buy comes in mike
the week of christmas
the closest game to
december 25th there's no nfl and you're
probably saying to yourself what how
could that be big cat that's going to be
terrible well guess what there is
there's nba there's college bowl games
we could win when when mike when the
college bowl uh playoffs gets to eight
games do you know what we can do on that
sunday we can play the first round of
the playoffs do you know it will be open
all the nfl stadiums across the country
that we can play those games in so we
will have eight we will have december
the closest game to this close sunday to
christmas off no nfl you can fill up
with bowl games we'll make sure we
schedule extra bowl games on that sunday
so no one loses that feeling of wow i'm
waking up for football on sunday now
mike here's the beauty of it okay after
the second buy that the whole league
takes and by the way may i mention this
is just a little help for roger goodell
football is family what other league
gives their entire league off for
christmas oh yeah that's the nfl they
care pr win boom
then after the christmas break so to
speak you have four weeks left of the
season you play the new years you or it
might be three weeks whatever the math
works out you play basically the regular
season until middle of january then you
got the playoffs the end of january
starts you know the second last week of
january is the wild card game end of
january is divisional round first week
of january or sorry february is the
championship round you take a bye you
let the nba have their all-star game
then you have the super bowl on the the
third week of february guess what
happens after that mike presidents day
the monday after super bowl sunday we
now have the monday after super bowl
sunday off i just fixed the entire nfl
schedule and let me throw an extra thing
on top mike i'm on a roll 17 games it
feels weird right because you have the
perfect setup right now with the nfl
schedule where you play a different
division every single year all four
teams you know what we do with that 17th
game mike we make
cross-conference rivalries based on
geography
the chicago bears should play the
indianapolis colts every year you have
said this the tennessee titans should
play the atlanta falcons every single
year they're three hours apart the
redskins and the ravens should play the
the the uh raiders who are going to be
in vegas should play the 49ers we should
have the eagles and the steelers every
single year the chiefs and the packers
can play super bowl one the browns and
the lions i could go on and on and on i
have just fixed all of the nfl's
problems thank you mike i will take a
bow
okay
here's the problem with the geographic
rivalries those teams play each other
once every four years anyway so what and
then you play twice because there's a
rivalry now
yes you play them twice every four years
there's a rivalry they do so
giants jets giants play twice every four
years they play every year once yes they
play twice every four years you don't
think fans of those teams don't want to
see that like like think about the also
the geography like the the you can make
rivalries out of the fact that some of
these cities are two or three hours
apart and they never play they play once
every four years people would come out
and watch the steelers and the and the
eagles play every single year that would
be an exciting rivalry and then every
fourth year you do have the two games so
i i mean i fixed it all i fixed it all
all right let me back up a step i love
the idea of shutting football down for
christmas weekend whenever that sunday
is closest to christmas i love it now it
gets a little weird if christmas is in
the middle of the week which week do you
shut down here's the problem here's the
problem because you've ultimately
constructed a schedule that ends where
the nfl wants it to end and that is
president's day weekend
but
they are determined to get to 18 games
and it doesn't fit if you go 18. it
doesn't wait if you go away
if you take no if you if you shut down
if you shut down unless you take away
the buy between the conference
championships and the super bowl it
doesn't fit if you start shutting down a
week for christmas you can't fit in 18
games in a bye week yes you can might
you can start on labor day every day
they won't do it you'll never do it yes
they'll never do that they'll never do
that they've done it they don't do it
you hit that no no look uh-huh remember
i never lost a case i won they will
never play on labor day the ratings are
horrible on labor day they abdicated
labor day weekend years ago because
people aren't home to watch football on
labor day weekend it's that simple okay
mike then get rid of the bye week
between get rid of the bye week between
super bowl and championship week it's
stupid anyway it makes no sense anyway
there's a lot to do there's a lot for
these teams to get together in one week
uh
i like the idea if they were going to
stay if they were going to stay at 17
games forever i like the idea of
shutting down around christmas time and
getting it to president's day but
they're determined to go to 18. there
are owners who want to go to 18 now
jerry jones wants 18 now but you're
saying they're gonna go to 18 and not
give a second buy that's absolutely
insane i've solved this i fixed it eight
all right all right
i fixed everything look it says it right
there i fixed everything that's cool
that people are talking about it now i
fixed everything
all right uh so much for having a
meaningful discussion in the actual
terms of the offer that is pending but
we already did that and it's going to
read an hour you'll hear it again this
is good this is creative i like this it
gives us something to think about give
us something to talk about a little
something to laugh about but uh you know
i like creativity i just really think
that um it's 17 with a buy it's going to
be 18 with a buy and it is going to be
super bowl on president's day weekend at
some point say maybe 10 years from now
mike do you know what you are you are an
energy vampire when people have good
ideas when people are trying to be up
you just suck that energy right out of
them you're an energy vampire i was
riding high and then you poo poo it with
your 18 game schedule thing i still
think it works i still think that the
nfl gets a pr win because you cannot if
you're the nfl this is serious now and i
mean my my idea is serious as well
because it works and it's genius because
i'm a genius but mike you cannot have
all the health issues that have come to
the nfl come their way the last decade
and a half and then say we got to play
two more games and not give them an
extra buy you can't do that that is a pr
nightmare in my opinion this is where
that works where you say we're gonna
give them an extra buy it's going to be
christmas week and everyone gets to
spend time with their family and
football is family and they do a whole
commercial i'll write the commercials
for them i don't care i'll do it i just
want the full the monday after super
bowl to be off every single year
all right i like we would be off anyway
like it really matters for us why are
you i'm here for the people mike i'm not
fighting for myself i'm fighting for the
people that's why you know it works
because it's not even so it's not even
motivated by like my own selfish
interests i want the people to enjoy the
day here's the other thing too
other than the schools being shut down
and the banks and the post office i
don't think anybody else is off on
president's day
are they
i don't know we got it all shut down
it's not like christmas
we got it off for the first time in in
the history that i've been working at
barcelona for a decade we got it the
first time this year and i think it was
an accident like i don't think that they
realized that they gave it to us all
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports